Kim Kardashian and daughter Northwest  enjoy a mommy-daughter date night at the  Katy Perry concert the 37 year old  reality star and her little one attended  Katy's witnessed tour in Los Angeles on  Friday Kim posted videos from the  concert singing along to her husband  Kanye West's song et he collabed with  Katy on it back in 2011 Kim Katy and  North met up backstage after the show  Kim and Katy posting plenty of pics  together to Instagram the singer  captioned one snap told you I was the  secret Kardashian the trio's hang out  sesh happened on the same day Taylor  Swift's new album reputation dropped  doing better  [Music]  you